trois divisions aéroportées
35 mille hommes à bord d'avions et de
planeur militaires se poseront hollande
à 102 km derrière les lignes ennemies
avec un seul objectif
et on mettra enfin à loeb ce qui leur
tyrannie qui tient l'europe dans un étau
depuis près de quatre ans
[Musique]
ils sont à la recherche du coupable
apa connaît du papa travaille pour les
allemands quand terroristes dans ce
village dans la maison où je travaille à
fond en comble
hollande falic
on peut pas rester dans un seul endroit
michel tu vois bien qu'ils savent a
obtenu
passé à gaza
ils ont obligé votre frère a parlé
on est tous en danger non
il est pas question comprendre ce serait
signé notre arrêt de mort eh ben c'est
facile à dire pour vous vous êtes déjà
sur de mourir fou
c'est possible mais pas aujourd'hui
le succès de cette opération est entre
vos mains
[Musique]
ainsi que le destin de toute l'europe
bonne chance